[Music]
another week another Plane full of
medical supplies leaving Russia for the
ailing West this time for the United
States it would seem as though Vladimir
Putin's bounty knows no limits even if
it turns out that the US did pay halves
for this personal protective equipment
and ventilators made by the way by a
subsidiary of Defense giant rostec a
sanctioned company so this is a
sanctions breach I could have said no I
don't want it or I could have said I'll
take it and you know what I said I'll
take it
except for the raid things that we need
I take it while back in Russia this is
the head of the Alliance for doctors
trade union anastacio vasilieva detained
on her way to deliver protective kit to
a hospital in the novgorod region a
breach of social isolation or was it
because she'd been so outspoken about
what she calls the Kremlin's lies and
she was to us before her arrest
straining just honesty and beliefs
personal and yet Promotions Tanika Coyle
it's just not an uber good novelist Tom
Scott botanist coronavirus Murray school
construction era at the Buddhist
Institute own store a new Vice President
Putin the host remove Nautica versus
tiene cada uno Smith is booted Miskolc
are a solution for us with external
damage to sustain images Sarah knows
Shivani attacks really Vladimir Putin
has extended the lockdown till the end
of the month it's tougher than the UK
you can't go out for an hour's exercise
a day if you're found to have broken the
rules you'll be fined
even jailed for up to seven years if you
end up infecting others
though it's only Chechnya which enforces
the rules like Red Square is almost
completely empty there will be nobody
visiting Lenin's tomb for probably quite
a long time and as this virus spreads to
almost every Russian region with
community transmission in half of those
you get the impression that Vladimir
Putin is more interested in the
political point-scoring than he is in
the actual public health implications of
all of this leaving it up to his
underlings to actually try and contain
the spread in regions like Komi that's
not working 53 people caught the virus
inside this hospital the patient zero
reportedly one of the doctors to have
died one of them a nurse we are all
mothers we want to get home alive
these women say they're quarantined
inside the hospital and they're scared
they'll all catch it last week the chief
doctor at Moscow's main hospital
battling covert 19 who've lad Amir Putin
had met and shaken hands with six days
before tested positive for the virus he
would have had all the appropriate
equipment but health care workers
outside of the big Moscow clinics don't
and as elsewhere they are terribly
vulnerable here in some meters Berg they
are begging for the protective kit to
keep them safe to treat patients with
kovat 19
as he dispatches more planes packed with
medical supplies abroad the latest match
to Serbia they hope their leader is
listening to the growing alarm of his
own people
Diana Magnay Sky News Moscow